good morning hank it's tuesday so i need
your help with the thing i'm working on
i need to learn some jokes but not just
any jokes i like jokes that are funny
obviously but i also like it when
they're just like a little bit sad to
give you an example of the kind of jokes
i'm looking for today i'm going to tell
you my two favorite jokes and you may
have heard these before but but wait
will you hear me do them this time okay
so a moth walks into a podiatrist's
office and the podiatrist says what
seems to be the problem moth and the
moth says oh god doc if only there were
just one problem my father died and i
miss him terribly and worst of all i'm
worried that my uncle killed him and my
mother has taken up with this very same
uncle and i don't know what to do doc i
don't know how to respond to this i just
feel so lost at this point i genuinely
don't know if it's better to be or not
to be and the podiatrist is like oh man
moth those are really serious problems
and i'm sorry you're going through this
but but it sounds like you need to see a
psychiatrist i'm a podiatrist what
brought you to my office today
and the moth says oh the light was on
it still gets me i first heard this joke
from norm macdonald but it's very old
anyway what i love about the joke is
that i feel all the time like a human
being endowed with a soul making at
least free-will-ish choices all day long
but in fact most of the time i am a moth
flying toward whatever light i happen to
see i fly toward the light of money or
status or power or rage or whatever and
then one day unhappy and confused i look
up and i'm like why am i in a
podiatrist's office and it's only an
understanding that my default setting is
to fly toward those lights that i can
hopefully occasionally make slightly
more conscious decisions okay here's my
second favorite joke a man is visiting
his sister who's a farmer at her farm
one afternoon when the man sees a pig
with a wooden leg and he's like hey
farmer jane how did that pig get that
wooden leg and then the farmer says oh
that pig that's bessie bessie is an
incredible pig you know not too long ago
we had a wolf come into the pig pen and
we thought it was going to be an
absolute bloodbath but then bessie
charged right at that wolf and scared it
off and the man says so is that how
bessie lost her leg by attacking that
wolf and the farmer's like oh no but you
know not too long after that the barn
caught on fire and we would have never
been able to put it out except that
bessie ran to the house and started
squealing so loudly that we woke up and
she saved countless animals and the
brother says so bessie lost her leg
telling you about that fire and the
farmer says oh no she was fine after
that and the brother says i'm sorry how
did bessie lose the leg and the farmer
says oh you know a pig that's special
you don't eat all at once i like that
joke because it's about how powerful
people often think they are doing others
a favor by only eating them slowly like
mostly it's just a good misdirection
joke but there's a slight resonance that
informs my way of looking at the world
that's my favorite kind of joke so the
roman poet horus once famously wrote
that poetry should delight and instruct
and when making art it's easy to focus
on one or the other delighting or
instructing but my favorite jokes and
poems and novels try to do both they are
both delightful and instructive so
here's my question do you know of a joke
that both delights and instructs and if
so can you leave it in the comments
below i would also take a joke that
merely delights because i
i just need a laugh right now hank i'll
see you on friday
in case you're wondering what it's like
when i'm like uh filming but not for the
video it's like this sort of like mini
existential crises washing over me like
so many waves
don't be the farmer who eats the special
pigs slowly and the normal pigs quickly
that's a bad farmer maybe it's a good
farmer but
maybe it's the system that's to blame
not the individual farmer i think but i
think i think we have to share
responsibility on that one i think both
the system and the individual choice
just like last week's video about
stuffed animals